à l'écouté votre tête regarder fait
partie le renvoyer latent du centre de
loisirs les pandas j'espère que qui nous
apportera ce cadeau pour jouer tous
ensemble
mais chut on a lui demandé de passer
votre soir avait coulé agathe agatha là
qui fait quand même
elle a quitté quand même les cherry pour
vous faire kiffer pour faire kiffer ses
enfants on a envoyé celui qu est le
meilleur avec les enfants celui qui veut
plus ses enfants
celui qui est mon ami celui que je ne
quitterai jamais et oui c'est moctar in
france gardien on a fait ce qu'il a fait
pour les enfants dont deux quarts s'est
passé mais non baba
mon tarif est à saint-aubin châteauneuf
toile 8,9 3par qui fait les enfants des
prêts allez c'est parti
mais avant de la dalle
mokhtar in ange gardien je suis venu
avec mon ardoise magique de tout ce que
vous allez me dire je vais dessiner ici
et peut-être ça va apparaître toi tu
veux quoi comme jouer il monte commando
quand j'entends bon comme on fait tout
en coûtant une moissonneuse batteuse
alors moto balançoire piscine piste
merci à tremper des légumes maison un
toboggan et un mac etc
en effet les deux en même temps on voit
tous les bonbons les yeux regardez même
mois jamais 1 on est monsieur lannoy
oui la star écouter à 3 on va tout à
fait des droits pour tous ensemble voilà
le match
oh
vous a plu aux enfants parce qu'on dit
j'ai deuxième surprise pour vous tout ce
qui doit après a maintenant qu'on va
deuxième surprise c'est baba qui a tenu
à vous faire mes cadeaux tombés d âge je
dis non à temps partiel ou total nous
battre
on dit merci qui j'ai pas entendu
pour moi c'est fini
alors tous les canaux c'est pour tous et
merci aquarelles en tout cas merci merci
à mattel tout ça qui ont fait un travail
fabuleux et il ne s'est pas un amour
mokhtar ainsi il est super avec les
enfants font tournoyer les enfants et
ils ont adoré veulent même que vous
reveniez on va essayer de revenir en
tout cas merci à vous on est mal merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci merci
d'avoir avec nous